all right cat hi cat where'd you grow up
where are you from originally I was born
in the valley but then I had 10 years of
my like my childhood was in San Diego
and then I came back to the valley so
it's been like just the valley in San
Diego okay
what was your childhood like
you know
it's pretty heavy question because my
childhood was really hard and difficult
and I like my mom had cancer for 12
years of my life
and
it's really hard to see somebody suffer
so much like so hard and living in such
extreme poverty and only having medical
she never really got like the best of
care so growing up being the only
daughter I was always by my mom's
bedside
shined a lot in me when she should have
been telling adults the things that she
wanted to she felt more comfortable
talking to me because we always had a
really open relationship we we were
always really open with each other my
mom taught me that being yourself is
like the best thing that you can do for
yourself because then you'll know who
why people like you because you're being
you and when people like you for you
it's what's important
like even if I did see yourself for a
lot and even though at times she
it didn't even feel like it was my mom
when the cancer got really bad like
there's such shifts in people when they
start chemo when they start
um
pain medication when they when they
changes people it changes people cancer
changes people I always describe it as
seen somebody rot from the inside out
and
as a child as an as the only girl I had
two other brothers but being the only
girl and seeing another woman the woman
that was my best friend my everything go
through so much I
I was really depressed as a kid I didn't
really have that many friends because
my mom she grew up she got abused by
like a lot of people and she was always
really scared of her only daughter going
through the same thing so I was like
pretty sheltered and kept inside
um being in a Hispanic home being the
only woman you're like literally the
gold of the house like everybody has
always tried to keep me safe made sure
that I'm I'm not going out when it's
dark time like it's always been like
that I've always had to deal with this
closeted
um
side and I think I stopped closeting
myself the moment that she like died
like she committed suicide and in the
room right next to me and
I was the second person to find her
I don't think like every morning I wake
up and I have such bad PTSD it doesn't
flake that every day I see it every day
I see it it's
nothing easy it's it's something I I've
been trying so hard to like get over it
I like I've been through therapy for
like eight nine years now I've been on
so many different meds um
it's just hard and
when I turned 14 and I had my first
boyfriend I feel like I just started to
Rebel like against what my family wanted
like all they wanted me was to be safe
but to me being safe was [ __ ] boring
like so boring like
I spent most of my time inside I wasn't
allowed to go to birthday parties I
wasn't allowed to go to amusement parks
I really wasn't allowed to do much
growing up
and whenever I did do anything like bad
like academically in school anything
like that I was constantly punished and
ridiculed and
it was really harsh
but when she passed away and I didn't
have all of those
heavy expectations of my mom anymore I I
feel like I just I sank deeper into a
depression
I I stopped eating when my mom passed
away
like in as little as six months I lost
like 40 pounds
and it's just really hard to like
go through what I went through not even
to begin to
talk about my dad and how he just God
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] of a man like
you wouldn't steal somebody's pain meds
when they're going through cancer you
you you wouldn't
torment somebody and hurt them and
manipulate them and then try to hurt the
kids like my dad he hurt my brother a
lot I saw him get hit a lot I saw
I saw them fight a lot my mom and dad
they were awful I remember one New
Year's they were fighting so bad that me
and my brother had to get in the way
and it was and it's not the only time
that we had to get in the way of my Mom
and Dad we were scared of my dad killing
my mom
and
it's just weird I have this weird memory
it was like literally the Christmas tree
it was New Year's we were watching a
movie all of a sudden they just started
[ __ ] tackling and fighting right in
front of us and and me and my brother we
just had a repent that we got up and we
just started kicking the [ __ ] out of him
get off of him oh get off
and then
instead of him getting help or or maybe
hey why don't you take it down with the
math like can you stop [ __ ] doing
math can you stop doing uh what the [ __ ]
he he like does some kind of gas that he
like [ __ ] I think it was even
gasoline he was sniffing gasoline he was
stealing my mom's meds he was on meth he
would come back all types of tweaked out
all types of tweaked out that is just
and then he would be awful awful to
everyone to everyone he would hurt my
mom he would hurt my uncle he would hurt
me you hurt my brother like
it was
and then when he got out of our Lives
because we're just like dude you are not
helping the family at all you're hurting
everybody and when
and then like my daddy turned to me he's
like
you really want me to go and I'm like
yeah I do
and he acted so hurt he acted so hurt
but I waited it felt like he was
manipulating me into being like yeah say
yes me I'll say yes say yes let me stay
let me stay
I said no and then after that we we
didn't talk for years for years
which was bet for the better because my
mom was going through like the worst
parts of her cancer and she didn't
[ __ ] need that sack of [ __ ] around
because he really was just a sperm donor
that's it that's it that's it he wanted
he wanted the the payoff of having a
family not the the hard work that you
actually have to do to raise a family
like he was perpetually in and out of
her life
just Saga [ __ ] like he's not even around
anymore like but we haven't even gone
through a quarter of my story yet so
like when we kicked him out he was out
and my mom she was like alone
and she was dealing with the cancer on
her own which made her fall into like a
deeper depression because it just felt
like my dad never cared about her pain
and suffering he he
just uses people he was just one of
those people that just uses people and
he's a great example of what I never
want to be
that's for damn sure
so my mom suffered for cancer by herself
without my dad the last few years of her
life and they were really hard because
we're also dealing with a custody battle
with my little brother my little
brother's dad had took him away and made
up a whole bunch of lies about my mom
about how she's not a great mom but my
mom cherished my little brother like
with everything like every ounce of her
soul she loved my little brother and and
for Omar for this
for his dad to be like oh you're hurting
him you're abusing him you're coming up
with all these lies like literally he
would call the cops and they would come
to our house and do checkups and
wellness checks and then all of us were
all the kids were just like why why are
they here we were just watching a movie
and chilling
and they have to question all the kids
and be like is everything okay here and
he would do it just
just to still be a part of my mom's life
and and if he enjoyed tormenting her
awful awful people I I've I've seen
nothing but awful men in my life
so when my mom passed away
I was 14 she she
I had a like my first boyfriend when I
was turned 14 and my mom was losing her
life and lost her battle in the end of
it but having that boyfriend I I feel
like I rebelled against my family like
really hardcore by having a boyfriend
because I would stay out late I was a
promiscuous I
I I did things early you know I I did I
got sexual pretty early but I feel like
that was the only other thing that could
counteract the pain that I was feeling
like I was feeling so much emotional
pain from losing my mom and the way that
I lost her it's like
so I started getting into more like
kinkier stuff like my first boyfriend
like he was like my first introduction
to like BDSM and into the thought of
being submissive towards your partner
and
it made me happy it made me happy that I
could do something for somebody and make
them happy and it can help me with my
pain
and we had this little relationship but
didn't last long it only lasted eight
months he broke my heart and really
[ __ ] up way even after I lost my mom
he he like he chose to break up with me
when I had to leave San Diego like he he
broke up with me when my family and I
were homeless in Texas
we were we were living in a trailer that
didn't even have a door they didn't even
have a [ __ ] door didn't even have a
window like it was really really bad
I've lost my childhood home that I lived
in for 11 years
so all of a sudden that
it's really bad
and in Texas since I was so different I
got bullied I got bullied really badly
and on top of having like my heart is
freshly broken on top of being bullied
it wasn't good I was I didn't feel safe
out there I didn't want to be out there
because I didn't want to lose myself the
same way my mom
took herself out
so one night when my uncle called me and
he was like Hey Mia
I have there's space for you to come
live with me in California I packed my
bags the same night I was out I didn't
care I didn't care I really didn't I was
I needed my uncle my Uncle George is
like My adoptive father he's the one
that's always actually given a [ __ ] like
took us to school made sure we were
dressed clothed fed everything like he
always gave us everything that he could
because he lived a really crappy life
his dad beat him
and his older brother used to beat him
too like my Uncle George has
his whole life
and I'm just blessed and happy to still
have him in my life he's about the only
person I can still be as
open as I was with my mom with him
because my mom and my Uncle George they
were like best of butts like friends
forever they acted like best friends
even though they were siblings
so just to still have him still feels
like a part of my mom
and it helps me helps me a lot helps me
every day
I like even though I've been hurt so
much
I love with such a fierceness I love
with such such a weight like when when I
give my heart to somebody it's like
might as well be out my chest
but it's only because I know what
extreme heartbreak and loss feels like
and and
it hurts me to see that my brother
hasn't really gone about it that way
and I think he's become just so angry
and lost and to everything that happened
to us growing up like
and it hurts me
it hurts that he hates me
Eric that he can't confine in me
cause I'm like the only person I can't
talk to I was the only other person that
went through what he lived through so
for him to see an enemy in me
been really heavy lately
he always fights with me he always
fighting with my Uncle George when he
should be like
more appreciative of everything my Uncle
George has sacrificed he got really
badly injured at work working hard for
us and
his disability shouldn't be thrown in
his face the way that it is it's it's
really [ __ ] up like my whole family is
filled with nothing but disabled
mentally ill
on people and I've just been surrounded
by by sickness and my way out of that
was with the Kink Community I I felt so
many things that were so extreme
that I felt like the only thing that I
could be into is just as extreme is the
way that I feel in me that's why I like
golf clubs that's why I like uh King
communities and that's why I I like
meeting people who are in my community
because I know that they have similar
stories I know I'll never be alone I
know that if I'm in the golf club and
somebody's bothering me oh there's cute
best believe there's gonna be people
like excuse me get them hands off there
girl you need a friend for it tonight
right and it's always like that I always
make friends if like all of a sudden I'm
having trouble like cool ass chicks will
be like yo
they'll help me through that and it's
like just always having my heart open
makes me feel like I'll always be safe
and it helps me not feel like I'm gonna
go through all the things that like my
mom made me fear when I was growing up
when I was sheltered and closeted but I
don't even think they realized how much
that hurt me socially because like in
the times that you're supposed to be
learning how to express yourself and
learning how to make friends in school
as a either being punished grounded or I
just couldn't go to school because
sometimes my mom's Cancer Treatments
were just too intense I remember at one
point
um
they started doing the chemo her hands
would massively puff up and her feet and
ankles just massively would puff up and
and she couldn't even like grip the
wheel
just just
turn on the car and drive and I remember
my brother used to get mad at her but I
would be right there like oh my God
because like for some reason I'm the
only one that she trusted enough to tell
that she was going through chemo
I never really understood why she would
keep their secret from everyone else but
if she told me to keep it a secret and I
was the naive 14 year old I was I I
always followed her instructions I
always took her to man's out and
commands and and I did what she asked of
me as best as I could so when she told
me I keep a secret best believe
foreign
I wish I would have
told people in the house I wish I would
have told people why she was having so
many seizures and
why she was so puffy and stuff I just
it's just always tell people be nicer to
her you don't know how much longer she
has with us and then just be like shut
the [ __ ] up you're no [ __ ] I'm just like
I'm just trying to be nice do you really
want your last moments with your mom to
be remembered like this they would just
get mad
my brother would always get mad he's
still angry he was angry he's nothing
but anger now
I go to therapy for it and I've been on
meds and it's not it doesn't affect me
like it did back then
but I do sometimes get myself into
sticky situations because
I'm impulsive I'm impulsive because I
feel like I haven't really been able to
live a life that I want to so
at times I don't make the best decisions
but whenever that happens I always wish
and pray that like I wish my mom was
still around I wish I wish I could hear
what she could say to me I'm sure she
could make me feel better right now
but I guess it's always a pain that's
going to always be on my shoulders
yeah but five years after losing my mom
tragically the way that I lost her I
lost my dad tragically he had relapsed
really really hardcore on on meth
and um
one day I just get a call randomly when
I'm in San Diego with my boyfriend
I just randomly hey I wasn't expecting
you to answer
um I have some heavy news uh your dad
died
and I'm just like what
what
how how did you die how could you
possibly died I thought he was gonna
live as long as [ __ ] Palpatine and
[ __ ] like this guy was as ugly as a Sith
Lord and he was supposed to look wrinkly
and ugly I was supposed to watch him
turn into a Despicable
old man but I never got that chance
because
too much meth too much alcohol
one of us all of a sudden he he uh he
got up on his bike well really really
Under the Influence any and he falls
over he breaks his shoulder clavicle and
it gets a heart attack from that so when
I was told that I was just like
oh
I I felt robbed I felt robbed because I
I used to always tell myself it's like
even though he wasn't her dad he
deserves to live as long as people can
live with his [ __ ] [ __ ] with his
misery and all the [ __ ] things that
he's done I wanted him to live old with
that so the fact that he got to Die
Young really upset me like really upset
me so like when I found out that that
happened I just prayed as hard as I
could I was all right all right you
can't be a dad IRL right you're gonna be
ghost dad now
so you better be keeping me safe
watching me from up there I used to
always say that to kind of like cope and
deal with like my Dad's passing it's
funny it's honestly just a joke now
but at the same time
I used to think like when when people
pass away I believe that the spirits
turn into like when they were healthy
and I believe that like maybe my mom and
dad were United in the in the afterlife
maybe maybe they could live what they
wanted to live now knowing what they
cause each other knowing the pain that
they caused each other and and it's
something I keeps my chin up I just hope
that my mom has company in the afterlife
now
so
like tell me about your life today oh
about my life today
um today
okay it's nice there's still a little
bit of turbulence in the house because
everyone's still kind of [ __ ] up from
what happened but my uncle and I we have
a really awesome relationship
he's like my best friend every every day
I get to say good morning to somebody
gotta eat with somebody we adopted a
doggie together her name's Mia she's so
sweet she really helped break the ice
between my Uncle George and I when I
first returned from San Diego
really helped break that ice so now I I
have one of the things that I always
wished for because at one point my uncle
and I shh we went down an
ugly path like when I when I was in high
school maybe 16 through
20 16-20 I was going through some
intense intense like
mental mental stuff like I
because after my mom passed away I used
to always think about like if I die
would I go with my mom again would I
have my best friend back like would she
finally be back in my life and I used to
contemplate her as a teenager all the
time all the time every time I made a
mistake I'm like [ __ ]
just do it shouldn't I
every time that I did get close to doing
that to myself I was hospitalized myself
because I knew I was too young
[ __ ] sake my mom died at 36 and that's
way too young for me to want to die at
17.
20 any of those ages just too young and
every time
that I did try to like attempt something
weird would always happen like I would
always hear my mom in my head like there
was this one attempt I was really
intense so I had like tried to
um hang myself with a belt
in the bathroom and it was just after a
really big argument I had with my uncle
my my uncle and I we had been violent
towards each other and the way that I
have this scar on my face was from a cup
that he threw in my face
and it
crooked it my nose a little bit I had a
double black eye
I ran away after that because I told
people I just tried to kill myself and
you still don't care I just felt like
nobody cared
felt like nobody cared so I I ran away
for an entire day
and I feel awful about it now because my
grandma was looking for me
she's really old
so I just feel bad that I that I did
that but I was just contemplating life
the whole day that I was away I was
contemplating life trying to find
what the [ __ ] is happiness what the [ __ ]
is it to be a happy human being is it oh
you just have a boring ass schedule you
just do the same [ __ ] over date but like
what is the happiness that brings it and
then all of a sudden it came to me it
came to me like I I was like begging my
mom to give me like an answer and
this is what popped in my head almost
said it was
you still have one of the most precious
gifts I gave you me
your life
don't throw it away
do not waste for one gift you always
have that I gave you your life
and that was the last time I attempted
out of [ __ ] eight attempts
that was the last one so I'm no longer
trying to take my life because I heard
those precious little words
foreign
ly after that I
um told my grandma I was gonna go live
with my dad
and
I regret it every [ __ ] day going
there because I saw how bad he was I saw
how he really never started trying he
got more deeper into drugs and alcohol
and he was really abusive and he was
trying to like use me he was trying to
be like oh yeah buy us a car learn how
to drive so you can drive me around
pathetic pathetic pathetic
I was really upset that he was trying
trying to use me similarly to the way
that he would he would do that to my mom
my mom was always the smarts and the
brains
and all that and
he's just always been a user
so
I I shortly after that I moved because
they were trying to make me work while I
still had this huge scar on my face I
still had two
huge black guys I was like literally
having to like kick on the [ __ ]
concealer color corrector powder powder
powder all the time and if you're
working that [ __ ] starts to like smear
off and and I remember forcing myself to
get a job just to try to make my dad
happy and I worked in a factory for one
day and
the makeup by the end of the day was
just
and it was so embarrassing that I
couldn't even go back
I refused to go back so then I was just
like you know what
you guys want me to be your maid you
guys want me to buy a car for you you
guys want all this and that but you guys
haven't even [ __ ] patted my back
giving me a hug said it's awful I went
through that instead they would just
talk [ __ ] about my uncle they don't even
know my uncle that's my dad that sack of
[ __ ] real dad isn't my dad my uncle was
a dad and even though he had just hurt
me so much years later
I forgive him I forgive him solely
because I took the time to work on
myself and I have a better version of me
that isn't as angry that doesn't want to
fight as much as I used to that will
never be in that dangerous violent case
anymore now that me and my uncle are
peachy keen and we've been through
therapy he got help I got help now we're
great and like he even says once he
starts working he's gonna get me the
laser treatment for the scar and when he
said that I started crying I was like
I thought I was gonna have to pay for
that but the fact that he wants to do
that for me just to show how sincerely
sorry he is I
how could I not accept that and I still
love him every day every day
I really hope that my brother can get
the help because to live in that anger
from our childhood
only suck you dry it would suck years
out of you when you look oh the fifth
time you're for it you just keep on
being so [ __ ] god Angry Angry Angry
doesn't solve anything anger doesn't
solve anything everyone should at least
respect themselves to give themselves a
moment to be angry by themselves so
nobody else gets hurt by such anger and
then and then
I don't know it's just it takes a lot of
courage to face your own inner demons
you know those eight ninth years of
therapy and all those hospitalizations
weren't easy
you weren't easy I don't know they
weren't easy the tears I've cried the
things I've had to accept
having to accept that you didn't deserve
abuse growing up when you were told you
up you deserve it you're a bad kid
all that and it's just like
we're not supposed to lift up to high
such high standards and learning that
later on through like friendships and
relationships and people have actually
been kind enough to like show me the way
knowing that well my childhood and my
adolescence was robbed for me due to
sickness and and all that but like the
people that do take the time to get to
know me I cherish them I cherish them so
much I cherish anybody that takes the
time to see my heart and my soul and my
journey and my battle and see me for who
I am all those things and and I don't
know
I just I wish people wouldn't think
being human is so wrong
like with all the social media and
everything all the perfectionism that
everyone wants to
have and all the money and the rich and
the glamor
man you can have all that and still be
miserable just saying you could be so
miserable even if you have everything if
you're not kind to yourself if you don't
have friends that love you for who you
are if you're not learning continuing to
learn and grow this body this Soul this
heart just become more human that's
ultimately everybody's goal should be I
want to be me I want to be me and I want
to be loved for me I don't want to
pretend to be no Selena Gomez no all
those [ __ ] celebrities like so many
people today
it's not worth it be human be you don't
be afraid to make mistakes as long as
you make the decision not to make those
mistakes again you'll be fine
you know
like [ __ ] people who can be handed the
worst things but you can even in the bad
things you can learn some good things
yin and yang baby is that what you'd say
is the most important lesson you've
learned in all of this yeah yeah just
being myself and and learning that even
in the bad things
like if you look at a bad thing you can
still find a little bit of good because
you went through that bad thing and
learned from that bad thing and then
having that strength and those new
lessons with you
will make you feel like shh I got a
million bucks right behind me
which it doesn't matter I've grown up
poor I've been homeless we've been
kicked out of so many places like money
really doesn't matter to me what matters
to me is ingenuity his empathy is real
human contact and and
it's what I love that's what I love
about being me about being a woman about
being the only daughter that my dog that
my mom had you know every day I try to
live my life like
to like show her that I'm still trying
to show her that I'm not gonna give up
you know and I'm gonna keep going and if
I need to tell somebody that they'd be
an [ __ ] you've been an [ __ ]
you know like but be funny about it be
charismatic about it like don't just be
a dick you know there's just better ways
if you want to be a little mean you can
at least throw a few jokes in there and
be like all right all right I get it I
get it I was feeding me and I get it you
know I don't know but it's all about
being a character that you're proud of
but the character not somebody else's
character your own character
that's what's really important oops
why I wanted to come on here and say I I
like don't trust people's white little
lies don't trust people too quickly
because
man oh that's that's an easy target
right there an open person to the wrong
person easy target it's always safe to
be with friends go on a group if you're
going to a club go in a group go with a
couple of girlfriends go with a couple
of guy friends like just stay safe it's
a Scary World out there everyone's
getting hurt left and right so if you
could just just be smart about the
decisions you make in any way in the
kink in the clubs and for [ __ ] sake in
the parking lot now like jeez we always
have to be so on top of it that
sometimes it just gets gets draining it
gets draining to know how scary the
world is especially coming from like a
really really like
cooped up at home like growing up like I
was really sheltered so having to just
be able to live out there and going
through and having the strength and
having the lessons and and all that to
keep you safe I'm grateful for it
honestly
it's awesome yeah yeah okay thank you so
much for sharing your story it was
really awesome meeting you Mark and
thank you so much for this opportunity
to just
give the world my low down you know
beautiful story thank you thank you very
much